- Good morning everyone,
and welcome to the day one
of re:Invent.
For those who had celebrated Thanksgiving,
I hope you had a great Thanksgiving
with family and friends.
If you have traveled
here, I hope your journey
was smoother than mine because
my travel was a disaster.
Let me tell you what happened.
I flew in right in the
middle of the winter storm
hitting the Midwest.
So due to that, due to the bad weather,
lots of the flights were canceled.
It's hundreds and thousands
of flights were canceled
and it was a mess.
When I reached airport, I got not one,
three different gate updates.
My phone said B12, whereas
the email alert said B17
and the monitor in front
of me at the airport
confidently said C7.
So I was standing at the
terminal understanding,
having the moment of clarity saying that
even if something as
simple as a gate number
can be become your adventure story,
that exactly the challenge that
we are going to unpack today
from fragmented systems to unified data,
to power, accelerate and
transform AML experiences
across your organizations.
So if that was your
travel journey, welcome.
We are around the friends,
however, we are finally here
and we are together in this room
and we are going to kick off
the day one of re:Invent.
Sorry, we are going to kick
off the re:Invent in this room.
So along with me today,
I've joined by two speakers,
one, Garima Sharma, VP of data Rocket,
and Ilia Fisher, director
of engineering at Rocket.
You're going to hear directly
from them what transformation,
innovation, the architecture, the wins,
and the hard earned
lessons that can help you
to accelerate your journey.
So let's start with a simple question.
What happens when your data grows faster
than you actually uses it?
I will give a second for you to think.
Honestly, that's every
enterprise right now.
That's true.
Every enterprise is accumulating
or collecting the data
more than ever from the more systems
and in different, many formats,
faster than their teams can organize it.
So what is the side effect of it?
Your data may be gets richer,
but turning the data into insights,
into actions into AI, that gets poorer.
So why? Because that
would be your constraint.
So that's when the
fragmentation creeps in.
So how does this actually
happens in the organization?
Is it like organization sit out
and say that, "Hey,
let's create a fragmented
mess organization?"
Definitely no.
So they'll set a goal
to say that move faster.
The three main things that
every organization set the goals
to their team is one,
innovate and scale out faster
and the third reduce the time to market.
These are the three
things that we always say,
but what happens with
every product launch?
When you stand up, every new use case,
you are going to solve a
problem from the local team
and you celebrate the wins.
But what happens? Fragmentation creeps in.
So under the hood, when
you launch a new product
or launch a new use case,
it comes with its own
customer data and it
comes with own schema,
own pipeline and own data assets.
Because of that, you
will be having different
multiple source of truth.
Individually they are successful.
But when you collate all
these things together,
collectively this is fragmentation.
And what happens when it
happens over the period of time
when you have this innovation
cycle, keep going on,
keep going on to your
organization that will accumulate,
you are ended up having
multiple source of truth
as I've given in my introduction,
the same flight from the same airline,
I'm getting the different gate updates.
Why?
Because you have multiple source
of truth which can derive the gate number,
the same that's going to happen
because of the multiple source of truth
that's going to be coexist
in your organization.
You don't know who owns the data
and what part of data is useful
and how the data going to be cleaned
or whether is it the golden
source of truth or not,
see ended up in those situations.
So let's take a quick poll
check, I want to test the room.
Whatever I spoke about until
now, the fragmented systems,
the inconsistency in the metrics.
Who resonates with this?
Please raise your hands when I call it out
few of the things.
Is your data spread across dozens
of systems in your organization.
Okay, I see a few hands raised.
And the next ones does
different teams define
the same metrics differently?
Awesome.
And the third one, how harder
it is you to find the data
or in a way, how much time
that you are finding the data
rather than using it?
Awesome. See, hand raised.
And all of our favorite
questions, all of the above?
When we don't know the answer,
all of the above is the perfect answer.
So everything we talked about,
the fragmentation has a problem
and is a side effect of the innovation,
or you can call it as a
tax that we are paying out
of the innovation that we have done.
So what exactly and why
does it even matter?
Think of this.
When the fragmentation system happen,
it's not just one of the
team is getting bottleneck,
it is across how you
turn the accumulated data
into insights.
How much value we are
deriving from the data,
that's where your downstream
systems are getting impacted.
And when do you realize that
you have a fragmented systems
in your organization?
When your teams are spending
more data in finding
the right data to use.
When your AML teams are waiting for you
to get your data cleanliness
and have the data ready
for them to try the models.
And as the AI is becoming a
biggest thing in the market
when you want to adopt AI,
and everyone complains about accuracy
because why the accuracy get matter
when you talk about rack
patterns, augmented generation?
Every time when you want to give
and if the data is not cleanse enough
and it's not clean enough,
you are going to impact
your accuracy.
That's why it is matter.
And different orations
fields have this pressure
at a different magnitude.
Let's imagine you are the
number one mortgage provider
in the United States.
And you are serving one in
six mortgages in the country.
And if all these work things are happening
that your data is flowing
from hundreds of systems
and thousands of processes and
build one top of each other.
And now imagine you are the leader
to unify all these systems together.
How do you feel and what
are the things comes
to your thoughts?
To share this firsthand information
Rocket is going through
the same transformation
right now at their organization
and to share directly
the inputs, let's welcome Garima Shema,
the VP of Data of Rocket
Companies to talk about
how the transformation
is going on at Rocket.
- Thank you.
(audience claps)
Hi, good morning everyone.
I'm Garima Sharma from Rocket Companies.
Rocket's mission is simple to
help everyone experience home
with which comes stability, hope,
and that sense of belonging.
Every architecture decision we make,
every automation we deploy
and every capability we build with AWS,
ultimately serves that mission
because for us in the end,
it is not about building technology,
it is about creating pathways to home.
Rocket has always been
an innovative company,
leading the transformation
in housing industry.
We were the first to launch
online mortgages in 1998.
fully digital mortgages in 2015.
We were also the first to take the mobile
and the very first to
deliver full e-closing
for all 50 states in 2019.
And just about two years ago,
we were the first in our space
to declare an AI fueled
home ownership strategy.
When you innovate at that pace,
naturally new systems,
new data and new tools
come with each milestone.
And here's the important part
in that growth and progress,
we realized that we
needed a data foundation
because for mission this
big, you need a foundation
that can match.
All that innovation was
incredible for business.
We were moving fast and
we were opening doors
to new capabilities.
But as teams were innovating and building,
we began noticing three distinct patterns
in our data landscape.
Not problems, but signals that
we were outgrowing the way
things were done before.
The first siloed and duplicated data.
As teams were building great solutions,
you can imagine they were
doing it often independently,
which meant similar data sets
existed in multiple places.
Second, as our data grew
in volume in variety,
finding the right data
for the right use case
became harder and time consuming.
And the third, as our data grew in volume,
we had definitely very rich data sets.
However, utilizing them
at scale for analytics,
machine learning and AI became
harder than it needed to be.
None of this was unique to Rocket.
Every high growth company
and innovative company
finds itself in such a situation.
But the key point here
for us was we recognized
that we needed a strong foundation
if we were to be
successful in our mission.
And once we recognized what
rapid innovation brings,
we were able to make a core decision,
which is move everything
to one unified data lake,
build on open table formats,
standardized ingestion,
and shared governance.
This was more than an
infrastructure choice for us,
it was an operating model
choice and a speed choice.
At our scale of about 10 plus
petabytes of data back then
and 30 plus petabytes of data now,
we knew that innovation
cannot happen rapidly
if our data was living on islands.
So we made a very simple
and most very simple decision
to adopt a most universal pattern,
bring everything into one
place, clean, consistent,
governed, and make it usable for everyone.
Let me show you what that looked like.
When we talk about
unified data foundation,
this is what we mean.
Rockets data comes in
every shape, structured,
semi-structured, unstructured,
and traditionally each data
type lived in its own system.
Once we got the lake, that gave us a place
where everything flew in,
in a standardized way,
regardless of the format,
everything followed
a standard pattern in architecture.
The data lake gave us a place
where we now finally had
a unified foundation.
And with this foundation you can imagine
the value explodes upward.
BI now has standard
definitions, machine learning
and AI teams now have
clean features at scale
and analytics and streaming become faster.
When we began modernizing
our data landscape,
our vision was simple,
build a platform that powers
every workload, real time
batch, machine learning, AI.
And we knew that we needed to
have one foundation, one lake.
So how we went about it,
step one was hydration.
We brought data from about
12 different OLTP systems
and brought them and
landed it into one lake.
The step two, and that lake
was of course on S3 based
Amazon technology.
Step two was automation.
We built standardized ingestion
pipelines using EMR and Glue
and adopted Parquet as our
default storage format.
Step three was security.
From day one, we encrypted everything,
disc file field, at rest,
in transit, and in use.
Aggregating 10 plus petabytes of data
into single lake gives access.
But as you all know, access
doesn't mean understanding.
And the next step for us was curation
to give the entire company a
shared language around data.
Instead of 30 teams
building their own versions
of customer data, we created Customer 360,
a single governed and
trusted view of the client.
The same happened for Mortgage
360 and Transaction 360,
which are single governed,
trusted view of mortgage loan
and a client's transaction.
Each one has standardized definitions,
consistent metrics, and clear ownership.
And this wasn't just
a data project for us,
it was actually a cultural shift for us
because we moved from duplication
to standardization, from tribal
knowledge to data products,
from searching for data to discovering it.
And once we curated our data layer,
we finally had the
foundation to operationalize
machine learning, AI and analytics
and real time decisioning at scale.
We not only improved how we used data,
but we also unlocked what
we could build on top of it.
And with this strong data foundation,
we created the runway
for something bigger,
to reimagine home ownership end to end.
Traditionally, the housing
industry works in silos.
You have one company that
helps you find a home,
another company helps you finance it,
and another company helps
you own and manage it.
But home ownership isn't three
distinct disconnected stages.
It's one journey.
And this is exactly how now
Rocket is able to treat it.
By bringing Redfin, Rocket
and Mr. Cooper together,
we are now able to support a client
across the entire journey.
And so we can help them find
home finance and own the home.
This foundation was important for us
because now it helped us create
solutions, impact clients
and business performance in
ways that we hadn't imagined.
And results showed up immediately.
During the early phase of integration,
40,000 servicing leads
seamlessly flowed into
our unified platform within
just nine days, clean, governed
and ready for activation.
On day 12, a client from the integration
went from application to
closing in just three days,
something that previously
would've taken the industry weeks,
our engagement engine began
analyzing conversations,
client behavior, and started
surfacing the right outreach
at the right moment.
And that drove up up to nine
points our banker follow ups.
we saw a 10% lift in conversion
across daily credit polls
and applications.
And when in September
the refi wave came in,
our systems were able to
instantly pull qualified clients
and activate personalized
outreach for them.
And that led to 20% increase
in refinance pipeline
just overnight.
We now can unify servicing
data, client intent
and behavioral signals and
that has led us to achieve
three x recapture rate as
compared to the industry.
When you have a such a strong foundation,
nothing is impossible for you.
But it took hard work,
it took a lot of effort
across the team and it took a
lot of alignment across teams
to show the value of a
unified data foundation.
And whatever I've shared so
far, the platform, the AI impact
and the data foundation
was not accidental at all.
It was the result of three things,
intentional architecture,
repeatable patterns,
and governance.
So let me now hand it off to my colleague,
Ilia Fisher, who will walk
you through how we made
all that possible under the hood.
So please welcome Ilia Fisher.
(audience claps)
- Thank you Grima. Whoa,
the microphone is working.
Good morning, re:Invent.
Well, it's so much energy in this room.
Do you feel excited for
this whole week of events?
I am excited, I am excited
to see so many folks here
willing to hear about the
modern data architecture
because it means to me that
whatever we'll share with you
today, you you'll take the
home to your companies,
to businesses and you'll evolve.
You'll evolve.
So in the years to come,
we'll be coming to re:Invent,
we'll be seeing new
patterns, new technologies
that maybe just one of
you will keep driving.
Let me start the presentation
with some personal story.
About 10 years ago I
was buying my own home
and I had to secure Rocket.
Sorry, I had to secure mortgage.
I didn't go to Rocket, I
went to a different broker.
So had a very interesting experience.
Maybe many of you went
through it buying a home,
collective pay stubs for
six months backwards.
You know, the bank statements,
the investment statements, the tax forms,
scan every document as a PDF.
And I had this HP scanner, so
I couldn't put a bulk of them,
just had to scan page by page
and then then email to my mortgage broker.
And I was very much
worried for two things.
Firstly, I hope that I'll get
the mortgage to buy the home.
I did about two weeks
later, received the answer
that I get the mortgage.
And, secondly, I was
very much worried that
there is not anyone else
who is buying their own home
with my identity since
I was sharing all these
confidential documents through an email.
And 10 years later, seems
like that hasn't happened yet,
who knows?
But I'm sharing this story
because maybe not as insecure,
but in terms of the latency
and the manual labor,
this is what Rocket Mortgage
was doing decades ago
and it's entirely different story today.
Decisions like this,
actually millions of them
happen in under eight minutes.
Everything through secure portal,
through secure connections
and people get, get the data, get, an idea
if they can buy home literally in minutes
or in in rare situations in days.
And how did it happen?
How did we went through waiting for weeks
until knowing that you can
get that loan to buy a home
to two hours or maximum few days.
And it happened because we
threw away the old playbook
of treating data as a call center,
sorry for the call
centers, hopefully no one
from a call center here.
And we turned the data to the
engine that runs the company.
210 machine learning models,
thousands of data pipelines
and all that runs in full automation
with zero human intervention.
This is what Rocket Companies do today.
This is what we achieved by building
a modernized data platform without hiring
hundreds of engineers, without purchasing
any silver bullet software.
All that by building that
modernized data platform,
which I'm going to share with you.
So buckle up in the next 20 minutes or so,
we'll go through the steps
of building that platform
through the architecture patterns,
through the design patterns
and I hope you'll find it
interesting and insightful.
So before a deep dive
into the actual services
that run the platform, let me step back
and share with you how
typical data platform,
modern data platform looks like,
which most companies converge on.
And it real boils down to
three clean decoupled layers.
And the first layer you
can see on your screens,
it's called ingestion.
It's goal is to get everything
in fast as it drives,
real time streams, APIs
file drops, SaaS connectors,
the Swiss knife of tool link, if you wish,
is supported to get the data
quickly into your platform
in a raw immutable format.
Ideally, like Garmima was mentioning,
using open formats like
Parkette, so that easy
to integrate the data
with plethora of tools.
So this is the first layer which
is called again, ingestion.
Just land your data as fast as it arrives,
reliably, securely in the raw format.
The next comes the processing layer,
transfer once but serve many.
So our data lake intends to support
so many different use
cases and we don't want to
ad hoc process data for each of them.
So we want to transfer once
this is the key statement once,
but then again, the data will serve many.
The overall data lake is
partitioned in three zones.
The first zone is raw.
This is a where the ingested data lands.
It's exactly what's
landed forever, unchanged.
The next level is process data.
So the process data is enriched clean,
the PII managed according
to these standards,
standardized to to the
standards you define
in your platform, right?
And this is the process
layer still not ready
for your business consumption.
So the conform layer is the third one
and it's data gets the
shape of business level,
domain aligned form.
So that many consuming
applications from a platform,
many consuming use cases
will find it useful
for their specific business case.
Now again, remember
transfer one, serve many.
So right, there are many use cases,
there are many business use cases.
However, we want to ensure
that our transformation
goes only once and produces
the data that we need.
All those transformations are
event driven when possible,
scheduled, when necessary,
declarative version controlled.
So you always know what's going on.
You have a solid audit trail,
how these transformations go.
And this is what platform's
goal is to provide.
And well, last but not least
is the consumption layer.
Call it a gateway to your platform,
one version of truth for
every possible consumer.
So again, one version of truth is the key.
We don't want to have silo data.
We don't want our the users
of our platform to think
which version is the right one.
So our platform provides
a unified service,
a unified data set for variety
of those business use cases,
including analysts doing
business intelligence,
genetic applications,
data scientists training
their models, all of them
point to the very same
well-governed data set
that our platform provides.
All that, this kind of overarching
schema of architecture,
if you wish not the architecture
model schema gives you
a highly scalable infrastructure,
gives you pay only for
what you use economics,
and we'll talk more about that,
and drastically over
lowering operational overhead
because you have like a
well formatted three phases
that your data goes through.
Your processing takes care
about so many use cases,
your ingestion, your consumption,
a Swiss knives easily extendable
to support new ingestion patterns,
new ingestion systems if you wish.
And on the consumption
all the new scenarios
that your platform must
support in your business.
But now let's go a bit more to the details
about each of those layers, how it works.
So today it's not about picking
a tool to make data work.
It's about building a
clean modular pipeline
to ingest process and consume
that is supporting so many
of those use cases.
And again, going back to the
ingestion, get any data in fast
and reliably, we would
support the API gateway,
running on elastic Kubernetes service.
We would support replication of data
between south services into S3 buckets.
We would support streaming
data with Amazon Kinesis.
All that is included
in our ingestion layer,
supporting all the business use cases.
And as soon as new business case arrives
to source data from a new
platform, from a new source,
we can easily extend the
ingestion and accommodate it.
And a bonus is that that
ingested data is landing in
an S3 bucket, which is our raw data lake,
raw data zone in the lake.
And as a result we get
out of the box versioning,
audit trailing of the data.
We built a resilient data lake
with geographical replication
and availability we needed.
And that's like an extra bonus that we get
when relying on AWS.
Next is the processing layer.
Transformed ones used everywhere.
So again, you see those
three standardized buckets
at the bottom, the raw, the processed,
and the conformed data.
Some people you might might
have heard, call them bronze,
silver, and gold.
So, and on top of them the
data processing orchestration
is event driven when
possible and time-based.
For heavy ETL workflows, we rely on Glue
as the most general use
case for highly scalable
compute situations.
With provision EMR, Amazon
managed Flink service helps us
to deal with streaming data.
And for a very lightweight
workflows, we find lambda
and step functions giving
very good economics
to process to make lightweight
data transformations
a personal hint, if you
rely on step functions,
it's an amazing tool, very
addictive with its friendly UI.
But if your data ends up
being virtually streaming,
what I noticed in my experience,
I had a situation where my step functions
became to run a thousand times in a minute
and bills spikes very quickly.
So it's always important to
monitor very well your expenses,
your costs, and using scholastic
services in your compute,
but also being scholastic yourself
to see how you restructure
your architecture
to send data via the right channels.
And so again, this is the processing layer
using all these tools.
There is no religion, like I mentioned.
You should be smart to
say which tool works
for which use case, what
gives you the right economics
and they all are elastically
scalable services.
So you know, in the data world,
you have certain periods of
the year, month, week, a day,
when you have high scalability needs,
you have other times when you
need lower scalability needs.
So using KWS, we are
getting that elasticity
of compute of the
processing and that gives us
near perfect economics
so that we pay exactly
for what we need and when we need
and we get that compute when we need
and with not much overdue.
Lastly, the consumption layer.
One platform, many consumers, same data.
That's that's the importance here.
The same data served for
every possible consumer
without duplication.
And this is what I saw so
many times in businesses that,
well, our data scientists
read from their data set
and our application
reads from their database
and they're not the same.
So my data scientist trained
models on something one
and eventually they're machine
learning based application
doesn't work as expected with real data
used in a different application.
So this is what platforms knows to solve.
Well by again, having that
one platform, one data set
for so many use cases, analytics,
BI, operational use cases,
machine learning, SageMaker feature store
pulling straight from the lake,
sometimes external sharing for integration
with other platforms like Redshift,
data sharing could just S3.
As a result, all those teams
work on the very same governed
data set without again
worrying that the user
something different, something wrong.
And so building this
platform with plethora
of those AWS services is
call it table stakes now,
but how do you make sure you
can actually operate at scale?
Because you could see
there are so many services
and I was saying, well guess,
we need to take care about the governance,
make sure that all our
data, all our resources
are tagged properly for right economics,
for right ownership identification.
We need to be flexible to
add new ingestion patterns,
new consumption patterns to we
locate like a hundred people
to paint in the toll?
No we do not.
All that drills down to very
well defined MLOps and DevOps
system behind the scenes
that automates that all
running it on autopilot,
repeatable, governed
and self-healing.
There are no tickets, there
is no co console click,
no exceptions, no heroics.
Otherwise we just wouldn't
be able to scale it for
so many consumptions, for so
many resources and use cases.
The moment the new data
lands in the S3 bucket,
in the ingestion on your left,
all the downstream is already
pre-provisioned the events,
the ETL pipelines, the
machine learning models,
which you expecting data to train
and basically runs seamlessly.
And what we did actually,
and this is a good pattern
that I recommend to you, I
want to note specifically,
initially we started with standard DevOps
source code first of course
infrastructure is code
and you provision your Glue, your lambda,
your step function, all that.
But then you realize that
the challenge still persists.
Like, okay, so I provision
my Glue job, so what about
that lambda that needs to trigger it,
I need to provision as well.
And then I need permissions from Lambda
to Glue jobs to execute it.
And then my Lambda needs to listen
to an event coming from S3 bucket,
so I need those permissions,
et cetera, et cetera.
That takes days even
so partially automated,
it takes a day sometimes
week for a team member
to build all this architecture pattern.
So with the well-defined
architecture that you saw,
we realized that we can
identify those patterns
and give engineers literally the blocks
of deployment patterns
which they can reuse.
And those blocks would
give them right away
the event listener, the
lambda, the permissions,
the Glue job, all the tags,
all the governance in place
for personal information processing,
for general information processing,
all that as a single package
so that they come take it
and deploy literally in
under 10 minutes instead
of spending weeks sprints,
build all that infrastructure.
Data scientists, they treat the model
exactly the same as the code.
When they merge the
changes to their model,
it automatically gets deployed
and using blue print deployment style
and with the right metrics,
with the right monitoring,
so that if there is a model drift,
in other words model
starts to produce results
which weren't initially expected
or any other software
issues with that model,
the role book happens automatically
and they just get an event, an
email that, well guess what?
The change that you tried to
make didn't go as expected.
We're all back for you.
Go to take a look tomorrow,
you don't need to go
to pager duty alert in
the middle of the night.
And same counts for
application API developers
building KPIs using canard deployments
so they can safely check how
things work in a lower volume.
And later on, again,
having all the automation
and metrics embedded into the
CICD pipelines deployments
which help them identify any issues early
before the impact customers
and automatically,
automatically heal the pipeline,
the changes that, sorry,
the issues which occurred.
So this is about the
platform and we covered
quite many areas.
The overall structure,
we covered the specific
implementation details with
those great AWS services
that you all know the open data format,
the MLOps and DevOps behind the scenes.
But how does this work, right?
This foundation isn't just sitting there,
it's supporting so many
enterprise grade solutions
in our company.
And those include, again, 360
APIs, well not 360 of those,
but few APIs, which
give you roundabout view
of your data models.
They support the data scientists,
they support the business
analyst with static dashboards.
But one of the most
exciting features to me,
and well guess what?
It's almost 2026. So how about it?
It's the agenda applications,
which is in my humble
opinion is the future
of business intelligence,
which will replace
static typical BI dashboards.
And what I'm going to try to
do now, I'll make a quick demo
to show how that Gentech
application works at Rocket.
Exactly the same one that I'm demoing you
is is being used by many of
our executive stakeholders
except yeah, except that
the data you'll see,
and that's a legal disclaimer,
it's synthetic data,
but everything else is true
and valid exactly as it works.
So let me see how we make it work here.
Just do one, just do one click.
Okay.
That's, we'll be playing video and okay,
it's actually working.
We'll be playing video.
I'll be posing to catch up
and tell what I'm showing.
So what you are seeing in this
browser window on your screen
is the system, I wouldn't
call it platform,
it's the system we developed enabling
not so technical users of our platform
to quickly stand up new agents
for their business use cases.
The interface is very intuitive.
You don't need to be a
too technical person.
You explain the data sources
that you want to use,
you explain the context
that you want to get,
the information you want to retrieve,
and then the system allows
you to create a new bot,
a new application which we'll talk
and with the very same
data set behind the scenes
and produce for you the results.
Like I'm going to share with you.
One note probably all of you are familiar
with the ChatGPT and Gronk
and many similar systems.
It's not the same, it's
not the same as the chatbot
that helps to polish your text
or some fine general
information on the internet
or elsewhere and telling you,
"Well please verify the data
because you know, it's my best effort."
In this case, all the data is sourced
from the same data platform,
which we've just showed.
So the APIs, the BI
dashboards, and these agents
get it from the very same data source
and you can rely on the
data as the true source
of truth for your analytics and for making
executive decisions.
So let's continue the playback.
Well, in this case, we'll
ask a very simple question.
It is just so little on the
screen, hardly can see it.
We'll ask a simple question.
So what is the average
mortgage amount right now?
And the agent will go and
the agent will go on behind
the scenes, will will
fetch this information.
We'll fetch you the data
in a matter of seconds.
You don't need to think how
you run those SQL queries.
It's all very much interactive.
And the average loan amount
in September was $288,000.
And if you're very curious
how the agent receive the data
or you just want to get
some technical insights,
you go to the SQL tab and it
shows you exactly what data
was made to our analytical
data stores to fetch the data.
Okay, but what if I
want to split this data
and reorganize it by state?
And if in in the old
world, I would need to go
and think how do I build my queries,
how to test multiple times,
then how do I visualize that?
And here you go, using
some natural language,
you quickly get the table
of all the low average,
low on amounts per state,
the number of those loans,
if you wish.
You can visualize this data
in a variety of graphs,
the pie, the line charts depending.
You can embed this data
in any of your reports
and obviously also have that SQL tab
to see how it works.
Well, but what if I want
a bit more analysis?
Tell me what it needs.
So I can ask agent, well
analyze this data for me
and the agent will right
away give you key insights.
They'll give you the premium markets
where people take most mortgages.
They give you the regional trends,
all kinds of information
that can be valuable
for you if you are a business analyst
or just a team member
associate generating a report
about the last week, the last month, which
by the way can also be
automated using this platform.
And what if you want to
cross reference those loans
with the interest rates in ease, right?
So you don't need to
think how you write query,
how you test query, get right
away all the information
and the agent spits it out in seconds.
Again, you can verify
the query it provides,
you can filter, you can
visualize in different graphs
how again, those loans
amounts, the numbers
and the interest rates all
correlate to each other.
I can go ahead and ask to analyze deeper
all this information and
at the end of this analysis
I'll get a full fledged
report for my mortgages
and for the interest rates in September,
I can learn from that
report about the states
with high mortgages where
people take high mortgages
and how it affects the interest rates.
The agent will tell you, well
the interest rates are low
in those states and the
opposite happens in those states
where the mortgages are
the loans bit smallest.
So all that gives you
that kind of interaction,
which you can again just grab this report,
sharing your newsletter,
sharing your presentation,
sharing in your narrative updating
your business stakeholders
and also the insights,
the insights based on
the very long experience
of how a company, how these
trends affect the trends
and affect the company.
So again, all that is
not some kind of a story
or fairy tale I'm sharing.
It's not a POC running on this laptop,
it's actually running in production today.
Actually tens of agents like
this running in production
based on the very same data platform
that I presented to
you guys and helping us
to drive the business efficiently.
With saying that I'll pause
the microphone back to Sijan
to our senior architect and to wrap up
and tell more about some of those services
behind the scenes that drive the toll.
Thank you guys.
(audience claps)
- Awesome. Thank you Ilia.
Okay, so far what you
heard about from Rocket is
how they have transformed
their organization
to be ready for the air readiness
and as the executors at Rocket had said
AI fuel home ownership and how
the foundation has been built
to power the vision that executives
has been set for our organization to take.
So let's see how they have got it there.
So we always see a three patterns at AWS
that most of the successful
enterprises have followed.
So, and the first one is aggregate.
So the principle here is
you have to unify your data
from the different data sources.
So either it is
structured, semi-structured
or unstructured data.
Bring all the data together
into a single place
and choose one standardized
format as an open table format.
Here in this case Rocket
was using an Apache iceberg
on an Amazon S3 tables.
So what happens when you do an aggregation
or unify your data, it
removes the fragmentation
and it'll help accelerate
your downstream systems
and downstream teams.
What is the second one? Curate.
So once you unify the data,
as Garima rightly said,
instead of multiple teams
billing the same data
again and again you
became the data products
like curate the data into the dimensions
or the dissect the data, unified data,
into the right dimension
that can be helpful
for your teams to take advantage of
rather than the rebuilding it.
So, the second one is curate.
So, and which services
can be helpful in having
curation stage, Amazon, EMR, Glue catalog
and the data zones.
You can get all these different services.
I'm just naming few, but
you can build your systems
into modern the curation systems.
So what happens when you would love to go
one more step ahead.
Hey, I don't want just curate
and have that data lake,
one more other table within our data lab
or the data warehouse or the data lake.
Like why should you do that?
Okay, let's have the
data sits into curation
into one of the data formats because
as Garima said about the
data products Multi 360,
Customer 360 and the Transaction 360.
So once you have these
data products curated,
make them accessible via
APIs so that it's readily,
easily consumable for all
your downstream systems,
even the agents demo that Ilia showcased
because those APIs are readily available,
you can accelerate your agentic systems
in your organization.
How many of you here are
building AI agents right now?
Okay, good.
So if you want to accelerate,
you need to have this
data foundation ready
and have your data products
as an extended APIs.
These are our LinkedIn profile QR code.
If you're allowed to
scan, please free to scan.
If there is any follow-up
question that you would like
to have after this, we are happy to help.
And once again, thank
you for choosing to spend
first hour with us and happy re:Invent.